Musik Ja, was ich auch tu liebe, du mein bester Freund, komm retten wir die Welt. Und für nicht weniger sind wir hier heute angetreten, um die Welt zu retten. Erneut ein 372. Mal natürlich, wie könnte es anders sein mit Stefan, Maria, Tietze. Und Florentin, Pasquesi, Will. Gut, vielen Dank. Und natürlich der dritte bei uns im Bunde, unsichtbar, aber macht sich trotzdem bemerkbar, Asch. Asch ist immer bei uns im Herzen mit dabei. Michel hat dieses fantastische Intro geschrieben und beweist, dass Pokémon-Musik auch romantisch sein kann. Und wir nicht singen können. Richtig, genau, das wird einem dann doch mal wieder relativ deutlich. Und wir weder singen, noch reimen können. Die beiden wahrscheinlich wichtigsten Fähigkeiten, wenn man Musiker sein will. Kann man reimen lernen? Ich meine schnell reimen, ich meine Freestyle reimen, ich meine, und dann jetzt müsste was Cooles kommen, aber kann man das lernen? Wahrscheinlich schon, oder? Ich glaube, das ist eine Fähigkeit wie andere. Ich glaube auch, dass Kollege und Fahri... Du glaubst, es ist genauso eine Fähigkeit wie alle anderen Fähigkeiten auch, die man einfach erlernen kann? VHS-Kurs Reime und dann sitzt du da und dann sagt die Lehrerin, so Kinder, Delfin. Schmelfin. Schmelfin ist kein Wort, Flair, das haben wir aber gesagt. Das musst du dich nicht freuen, das ist kein Wort, Schmelfin ist kein Wort. Delfin, hat jemand eine Idee? Kollegah vielleicht, da hinten? Ähm, Benzin Benzin, sehr gut Ja, danke Ja, warum bist du im Kurs, wenn du nicht lernen willst? Meine Eltern haben mich hier hingesetzt die haben gesagt, Kollegah Immer diese persönlichen Geschichten bei jeder fucking Antwort, ey Aber sei doch froh als Pädagoge, dass du so eine sehr offene Klasse hast, die immer gerne sagen, was gerade das Problem ist. Ja, aber die Klasse, ich, also Revision jetzt, ja, vielen Dank, Herr Direktor, ich weiß, ich hab da viele offene Leute in meiner Klasse, ich hab aber das Gefühl, dass sie das manchmal nutzen, um einerseits... Nutzen schmutzen. Genau, wir wollten ja noch mal den Anfängerkurs machen, aber ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass sie das einfach nutzen, um so ein bisschen die Unterrichtszeit zu füllen. Weißt du, die wissen ganz genau, wenn sie mit ihren Geschichten irgendwie sehr aufgewachsen sind und die Eltern hatten wenig Geld und so, dann geht die Stunde schnell rum. Aber sie machen doch den Kurs Rap 1.0. Genau. Dann nutzen sie doch vielleicht diese spannenden, traumatischen Hintergrund-Stories von ihrenren einzelnen Charakteren aus Ihrem Kurs. Ich sag nicht Schüler und Schülerin, ich sag Charakteren, um die zu nutzen, vielleicht, Sie können die nutzen für coole Rap-Songs. Ich mag Ihre fortschrittliche Pädagogik auf jeden Fall, das gefällt mir gut. Wissen Sie noch, als der junge Sidolius gesagt hat, dass er aus dem Block kommt, sein Block, sein Bezirk? Ja. Vielleicht kann er das zu einem Song machen, Song sagt man ja nicht, Rap-Track. Vielleicht sollte ich ihn da weiter motivieren, ja, Sie haben recht. Vielleicht sollten Sie Sidolius den dritten, mit dieser furchtbaren Narbe, furchtbaren Narbe im Gesicht. Der sich immer so unter seinem Mantelkragen versteckt. Vielleicht sollten Sie den motivieren, daraus irgendwie meinen Song zu machen. Dass ein bisschen mehr aus seiner Hülle rauskkommt. Ja, das stimmt. Ich weiß nicht, mein Viertel oder so könnte der Song ja heißen. Ja, meine Gegend, mein Kiez. Was reimst du hier auf Kiez? Meine Ecke. Stefan, Tiez, komm mal da haben wir es doch. Schmiez, Tiez. John Tiez ist mein Name, ich habe überlegt, mir ein E zu kaufen. Ja, wirklich? Einfach auch um den Prozess. Für Stefane oder? Stefane Tietze. Ja. Nee, für das langgezogene IE. Es führt ja dann doch immer mal wieder zu Problemen. Jetzt ist es auch ein bisschen zu spät, ehrlich gesagt. Hätte ich vor, mal im Instagram-Handle oder sowas, oder so, etc. pp. machen sollen. Und jetzt aber, ich will einfach mal gerne durch diesen Prozess gehen. Aber meinst du, das geht, dass du einfach sagst? Ganz einfach. Da gibt es einfach eine Tabelle, jeder Buchstabe hat einen Preis, E kostet 160 Euro. E ist leider sehr teuer. Ö kostet 6000 Euro, so die Premium-Buchstaben ganz am Ende des Alphabets. Hinter mir sehen Sie gerade live diese große Anzeige, die sich verändert, diese Bahnhofsanzeigen hinter mir. Da sehen Sie die aktuellen Preise. Oh Schatz, da kommen wir morgen nochmal wieder, oder? Ja genau, also man muss wirklich sagen, heute wurden schon drei Ös gekauft und dadurch hast du hinterher, siehst du halt, der Ölpreis steigt. Der Ölpreis steigt. Meine Gattin Claire möchte unbedingt ein Öl haben, aber das sieht ja dann schlecht aus. Aber Claire verliert sie ja, und das A und das I. Ach, das können wir tauschen? Sie machen auch Tausch, Buchstabentausch? Ja, genau, klar. Also es ist ein Handel, es ist eine Börse, wie Sie hinter mir sehen. Ach, jetzt verstehe ich. Sorry, okay. Also wenn Sie mir ein A und ein I geben, verliert das natürlich hinten einen Preis, freut sich der Nachbar, der gerade am Nebentisch, der gerade ein A haben wollte. Ja, freut sich doll. Freut sich klischee-mäßig doll, wie im Comic. Oh, eine Sprechblase, eine Denkblase über ihm entsteht. Jihah! Endlich ein A. Ja, okay. Also ich glaube, das geht. Und dann habe ich herausgefunden, dass eine Schulfreundin von mir hat sich tatsächlich mal einen Buchstaben gekauft. Weil, also die Familie, die Familie. Um ihre Identität zu schützen, sag lieber den Namen vor dem Buchstabenkauf. Wir wollen ihren aktuellen Namen nicht leaken. Ne, ich kenne weder den Namen davor, weil, ich weiss nicht, ob das so aufgewandert ist, aber ein Buchstabe macht den Kohl nicht fett. Ja gut, aber trotzdem bist du bereit, mehrere tausend Euro von unserem Geld auszugeben, um dir einen Buchstaben zu kaufen. Ich glaube, es kostet nicht so viel. 80 glaube, es kostet 80 Euro oder sowas. 80 Euro für eine Namensänderung. 80 Euro für einen Buchstaben. Klar, und dann muss halt die Ausweise. Und wir kommen nicht nach New York, weil auf dem Flugticket ist jedoch mein alter Name. Wer ist Stefane? Naja, und dann hat sie, also die Familie war nicht so happy mit dem Namen, den sie vorher hatte, dem Nachnamen. Moment, die Familie war nicht happy mit ihrem eigenen Namen? Eigene Nachnamen. Okay. So, weil der Name, der ein Vornamen auch ist. Und ich verstehe das. Ich verstehe, dass es nervt, wenn der Nachname ein Vorname ist. Der Nachname ist ein Vorname. Wir sind Menschen suspekt, dessen Nachnamen ein Vorname sind. Aber kannst du dann einfach nicht deinen Kindern Nachnamen geben, dass der Vorname dann Schmidt heisst und dann heisst er Schmidt Markus. Es gibt auch eine Familie Florentin in München, in die ich mich lange Zeit einheiraten wollte, aber es hat nicht gefunkt. Bei keinem von denen. Ich habe wirklich alle durchprobiert und bei keinem ist der Funke übergesprungen, da sagte ich mir, nee, am Ende muss es dann doch die Liebe sein. Einfach for the gag, for the win, for the fun? Ja, für den Kick, für den Augenblick habe ich es dann versucht, aber am Ende hat es dann doch gescheitert. Florentin, Florentin. Ja, Florentin, Florentin hätte ich schon ganz gut gefunden. Ja, ist perfekt. Nee, und sie hat dann einfach, hat sich die Familie entschieden, hat sich abends hingesetzt, bei so einem Butterbrot beschlossen, Sparschwein aufgeschlagen und gesagt, komm, wir kaufen uns jetzt diesen Buchstab. Aber als ganze Familie. Ja. Und dann geht die ganze Familie zusammen, Oma, Opa werden abgeholt und dann geht man einmal schön zum Amt und dann kriegen alle so einen Kuchen, der dann aussieht wie so ein E und alle, ah, jetzt sind wir endlich die Moelas. Nee, sie heisst noch genauso wie sie, also phonetisch heissen sie es auf jeden Fall noch gleich, sie haben nur in Buchstaben zur Abgrenzung des Nachnamens gewählt, des Vornamens gewählt. Und ich finde das eine clevere Idee, ich mache das sehr. Okay, also wir haben ja einige Tipps mittlerweile. Ein Nachname, der ein Vorname ist, der durch ein Buchstaben nicht mehr erkenntlich ist als Nachname, als Vorname. Klarer erkenntlich ist und nicht geschrieben wird in der Vornamenvariante. Also statt, also Marcuse statt Markus. Zum Beispiel. Wenn du dann sagst, wir sind Familie Marcuse. Jetzt habe ich aber gerade noch gesagt, phonetisch hat sich nichts geändert. Phonetisch bleibt der Name gleich. Phonetisch, die Phoneme bleiben an ihrem Ort. Es klingt noch genau so, man spricht den gleich aus, geschrieben, sieht es aber nicht mehr aus wie ein Vorname. Ich finde das eine coole Idee. Ich war dabei, wir haben sie alle unterstützt. Ich war nicht dabei, das haben die der Vorher gemacht. Das ist das aktuelle Rätsel für diese Folge. Schreibt uns gerne eure Ideen und ratet einfach nach der Identität eines fremden Menschen. Und dann ratet auch noch die Adresse. Oder er ratet auch noch mehr als das. Okay, aber das müssen wir schon sagen. Falls jemand die Adresse richtig rät, müssen wir das schon dann sagen, ja du hast hast recht. Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr gering, aber ich finde, das muss dann schon gewertschätzt werden. Dann ist kein Leak mehr, dann muss ich auch sagen, laut, was ich würde erraten. Weil man sieht es dir eh an, du kannst eh kein Geheimnis sagen. Wenn ich jetzt sage Augustenstrasse 18, ja man merkt es dir an, dass es die richtige Antwort ist. Wie denn? Du hast keinen Pokerface, man merkt es dir einfach direkt an. Klar ist ein Pokerface. Nein, hast du nicht. Man merkt dir direkt an, wenn ich fünf Adressen durchgehe, dann merke ich sofort, welches es ist. Wir probieren es mal. Tize am Tisch. Die Adlerallee 8, Bahnhofsweg 15 und die Gisela Kretschmannallee am Stephansdom 3. Oh, da ist es, Mann, da ist es, man muss sich nur so ein bisschen braten lassen, man muss sich nur so ein bisschen braten lassen. Was aber eine idyllische Wohnung am Stephansdom drei. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Es gibt nur drei, am Stephansdom eins ist der Stephansdom, Stephansdom zwei ist der Souvenirshop, Was ist die Adresse des Kölner Dom? Steffansdom 3 ist die Adresse der Sünders. Ist Kölner Dom die Adresse Domplatz 1 am Kölner Dom? Das weiß ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe eh das Gefühl, es ist völlig egal, was man auf den Brief draufschreibt, der kommt an. Das habe ich auch das Gefühl, ja. Also das ist so, das passt schon. Ich glaube, da ist viel Raum für Problem, für Problem, für Dummheit.
Für Spielraum.
Das Leben generell bietet super viel Raum für Dummheit. Man kann so dumme Sachen machen, man kommt super oft einfach durch mit Rumgebullshitte. Ja. Also auch E-Mails oder so, da braucht man auch nicht genau die richtige Adresse. Aber da ist wirklich, da ist E-Mail härter einfach so. Oder wenn du einfach nur sagst, wenn du jetzt einen Brief schreibst an WDR.
Ja.
Ich glaube, du musst einfach nur WDR auf den Umschlag schreiben und der kommt an, der Computer sagt, äh, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, sag nichts, sag nichts, sag nichts, Publikum leise, bitte, Publikum leise. Das ist ein nervöser Computer, der hat es in Weh. Das ist ein alter Computer. Wir haben ihn in einen eigenen Raum gestellt, weil er die ganze Zeit schreit und sagt, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, äh, äh, die, die, die, ach, was ist das? Ich rufe gleich zurück, Schatz, hier ist gerade der Computer wieder so laut.
Ah, Trunk, Trunk, Trunk, Trunk, Trank, äh, Tranklweg, Mann, ey, jetzt hab ich's gleich.
Aber ich würde behaupten, ich habe wirklich keinen Pokerface.
Nee, hast du nicht.
Gar nicht.
Hast du wirklich nicht.
Das wird mir oft gesagt, aber so nach Monaten, so du hast, also man erkennt alles bei dir, also du bist ein Offensbuch, und ich glaube das auch.
Ja, du bist quasi eine komplett eigene Sprache, also wirklich Nervosität ist Lippenzittern, Desinteresse ist einfach weggucken und Augenrollen. Augenrollen, offensives Augenrollen. Da muss man dich gut kennen, damit man das versteht. Und ansonsten, wenn du lügst, dann flattern die Ohren so leicht nach oben und um. Ja, und es erscheint in so roten Blutgefässen Lüge auf meiner Stirn. Ja, genau. Aber das kannst du natürlich auch gut ausnutzen. Ich glaube, der beste Lügner ist ja der, von dem man denkt, der kann nicht lügen, von dem man denkt, der den ruft, dass er ganz schlecht lügen kann. Vielleicht ist es von dir auch nur so ein langer Plan, dass du bewusst immer ganz schlecht lügst und dann das eine Moment, wenn ich dir sage, sag mal, bist du ein Schläferagent des iranischen Geheimdienstes? Und du, nö. Nein. Okay. Das war deine einzige wichtige Lüge. Das ist schon wichtig. Sind Lügendetektoren vor Gericht zugelassen eigentlich? Nein. Nein? Sonst wäre es saulangweilig. Sonst wäre es saulangweilig. Sonst wäre es saulangweilig. Man lässt es nicht zu, weil es so langweilig wäre. Ja, das Volk gegen Stefan Tietzer. Einmal den Finger bitte. Haben Sie ihn umgebracht? Nein. Lüge und der Nächste, tschüss. Euer Ehren, ich kann mich um den ganzen Prozess zuzugucken. Ja, gerne, kommen Sie gerne auch während der Verhandlungen auf mich zu. Ich habe immer ein Ohr offen für alle. Genau, Clarice aus dem Publikum. Hallo, ja. Und ich glaube, ich spreche für uns alle hier im Publikum.
Nimm Sie das Mikrofon gerne.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ich spreche für uns alle hier aus dem Publikum, wenn ich sage, es war saulangweilig.
Und wir kommen eigentlich hier zum Gericht, weil es ist ja öffentlich, es war eine öffentliche Verhandlung.
Ja.
Und wir kommen alle hier und ich glaube, ich spreche, ja, ich spreche für alle, wenn es darum geht, wir wollen auch wie True-Crime-Sendungen irgendwie Spannung haben, Plot-Twists und coole Fälle. Das tut mir leid, da habe ich. Ich habe es überstürzt. Ich dachte, die moderne Technik kann uns hier helfen, Gerechtigkeit zu sprechen, aber Sie haben recht, ich lag falsch. Und wir dachten vielleicht, dass wir den Lügendetektor einfach abschaffen könnten.
Ja, bevor wir das machen, würde ich Sie noch mal gerne anstecken. Fanden Sie es denn wirklich langweilig? Ja. Ja, stimmt. Ja. Ich dachte vielleicht. Na gut. Okay, weg damit. Wäre doch gut. Also ich verstehe es. Und an die hunderte Lügendetektoren auf Müll, würde dann jemand kommen und die holen? Also angenommen, weil ich meine, es gibt ja bestimmt so Stichtage, wo es dann heisst, okay, der Kölner Ämter schmeissen alle Faxgeräte raus zum Stichtag und dann irgendjemand findiger tut, ein bisschen so ein Schlapphut vielleicht oder so, liest es in der Zeit, so, reine, das ist ja was, hier ist schon mal das Stichtag, da schmeissen die die Faxgeräte raus, die Faxgeräte werden aus dem Fenster hier auch. Alles, was, da stellen wir uns schön im Transporter, schön an Wertstoff auf. Wir stellen uns nach Ehrefeld an den Bergschau. Köln, Köln. Und dann kommen da die Laster mit den Faxgeräten und dann schütten die die alle in die Container und zwischendrin halten Leute ihre Kescher rein. Regenschirm umgedreht. Versuchen noch die alten Faxgeräte rauszuholen. Dieter, Dieter, rechts! Dieter, hol dir, der ist ein Grosser, der ist ein Grosser, schnell! So auf den Schultern. Und alle Kescher gehen rechts rüber. Ja, aber es kann sein, ich lieb das ja, Büroauflösungen und sowas. Ich lieb das, und in Köln war wirklich neulich mal eine Büroauflösung. Und ich dachte mir, ist ja amazing, es war auch so ein sogar ein cooles Büro, irgendwie Architekturbüro ehemaliges oder sowas. Das heißt, da dachte ich mir, das ist bestimmt mega geile Möbel oder sowas. So Modelle von Häusern, Zirkel. Oder einfach eine Kack-Schreibtischlampe. Ich war bereit, ich war ready, ich habe mich gefreut, ich bin da sehr früh aufgetaucht, war da, die hatten nur noch Dreck, es war nur noch Quatsch da, es waren eklige Tische da, es waren alte Geräte, die mit funktioniert haben, es waren Röhrenbildschirme da, es hat gar nicht funktioniert. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, lass uns die Erwartungshaltung alle insgesamt runterschrauben. Gute Idee. Es ist nichts so cool, dass man denkt, ah krass, das machen die, nein, das ist schon ein Red Flag. Es ist nichts cool, die wird nichts geschenkt. Das ist seine Botschaft, die aktuelle Ausgabe von Estefan, es ist nichts cool, Erwartungen runter. Ja, genau. So den Kurs der Erwartungen, die aktuelle Erwartungskurs und dann richtig in den Keller. Ganz in den Keller gegangen. Es gibt keine Wunder, alles ist sehr realistisch. Wenn man da hinkommt und die haben Dinge zu verschenken oder zu verkaufen, sind die wahrscheinlich nicht so toll.
Ach, das ist dein neues Tattoo, oder was? Es gibt keine Wunder.
Es gibt keine Wunder. So ganz über den Unterarm.
So einer ganz trockenen...
So dass du es lesen kannst, aber alle anderen es nicht.
Ja, um mir die ganze Zeit zu sagen, schraub die Erwartungshaltung runter.
Da habe ich in so einer ganz langweiligen Arealschrift hier stehen, es gibt keine Wunder.
Ja, es gibt keine Wunder, Punkt. Auch kein Ausrufe zeigen, so ein Punkt. Wunderpunkt. Es gibt keine Wunderpunkt. Gibt es viele Satzzeichen in Tattoos? Also wirklich einfach live, love, love. Nee, ich finde gerade bei Rage oder so, dann auch in so einer krassen Schrift, du brauchst kein Ausrufezeichen. Du brauchst es nicht.
Carbe Diem Ausrufezeichen.
Du hast relativ selten Satzzeichen.
Du brauchst es nicht. Ich habe auch schon mal gesagt,
in Logos und sowas, die sind ja oft
selbstbewusst schon, die stehen schon selbstbewusst
da. Läden sind
eine selbstbewusste Art.
Wenn jemand etwas verkauft, ist
ein Ladenlokal über drei Stöcken
von Job, ist eine harte Ansage, ist selbstbewusst.
Aber gerade Job hat ein Ausrufezeichen.
Eben, eben. Und haben die gross oben beleuchtetes Signal, du brauchst das Ausrufezeichen nicht.
Nein.
Ist das ein Zeichen für Schwäche? Ich meine, was ich gerne mag, ist der McDonald's-Apostroph, der Genitiv-Apostroph, McDonald's.
Und ich würde sagen, wenn sich jemals ein McDonald's auflöst, ich bin der Erste, der versucht, diesen Apostroph zu holen. Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr mit so einem Seil, mit einem Haken dran, würde ich einen Apostrophen, weil alle wollen das M, alle wollen natürlich das M, das geschwungene M. Und während alle sich um das M streiten, bin ich, bin ich der einzige, der von da, ich komme den McDrive falsch rum, ich komme vom Parkplatz den McDrive raus. Wahnsinn. Und dann, zack, hole ich mir das Apostroph. Wenn Ladenauflösung McDonalds ist. Ja. Es gibt auch bestimmt irgendeine Community-Auflösung in DE oder Reddit-Slash-Auflösung oder so, wo Leute dann so, ey, übrigens, da löst sich was auf und dann kommen die da hin, wobei man da aufpassen muss, weil ich würde genau die Community nutzen, um alle irgendwo anders hinzulotsen. Wenn ich wüsste, der McDonald's löst sich auf, würde ich sagen, oh, guck mal, da hinten, das Postamt löst sich auf, alle stehen da, die Vollidioten mit ihren Trucks und ihren Keschern, währenddessen reisse ich jeden einzelnen Buchstaben von McDonald's runter und lager die ein. Fritteuse? Fritte, nehme ich. Dieses Grill, dieses Pommesgrill, dieses Gitter. Auch wenn du eine Sache von McDonalds haben dürftest, was würdest du nehmen? Aber du musst bedenken, die Soft-Eismaschine ist auch meistens kaputt. Also das musst du damit einrechnen. Diesen Bestellautomaten. Diesen Self-Checkout-Bestellinstink. Und dann wird dir das geliefert auch, oder was? Also, an 100 Prozent der Orte, wo die Dinger stehen, kriegt man dann da auch das Essen. Also, allein empirisch belegt, müsste ich mir so ein Ding in die Wohnung stellen, dann würden die es zu mir liefern. Ja, ist okay, finde ich nicht schlecht. Funktioniert so logisch? Ich glaube, ja. Lass mich kurz an meinem Tattoo checken. Nein, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Seitdem ich das Tattoo habe, wirklich alles läuft besser, Erwartungshaltungen sind unten. Sind deine Erwartungshaltungen immer oben? Nee, auch ganz oben. Ich habe die mal reduziert und habe gemerkt, dass es ... Wann hast du die letztendlich reduziert? Ich glaube in Folge 290 oder so, da habe ich gesagt, heute vor der Aufnahme müssen wir einmal drücken und seitdem geht es mir wirklich besser. Mir geht es wirklich besser, aber tatsächlich, ich kann ja zum Beispiel nochmal einen Bogen zumachen und zwar habe ich letztens meinen Abfluss repariert. Oh! Also die Chronisten können jetzt genau den Punkt Pumper, den Punkt festsetzen, wie viele Tage ich jetzt keinen Abfluss hatte. Ja, das lange.
Pumper und ja, ich habe genutzt die reine Kraft der Chemie. Ich habe mir so einen Abfluss, Abfluss, Etzer, so wirklich so ein Rachenterror, einfach so ein Schlitzmichaufgel genommen. In orangener Farbe, dieses orangene? Genau, in orangener Farbe. Warenfarbe. Wo einfach drinsteht, wo ich einfach die komplette Flasche reingekippt habe, um dann zu sehen, ja, 250 Milliliter leichte Verstopfung, 500 schwere Verstopfung, ich habe gleich alles reingeballert. Und dann einfach, sollte der da kämpfen da drin, da habe ich ein bisschen Wasser nachgekippt. Es ist immer noch nicht ideal, es läuft nicht alles ab, aber ich kann so nicht mehr weiterleben, es geht nicht. Und deswegen da auch, wenn du lang genug ohne Abfluss gelebt hast, ich bin wirklich gerade in einem Hoch, weil die einfachsten Dinge, allein, weil normalerweise davor habe ich gelebt, immer wenn ich was abgewaschen habe, ist das Schmutzwasser in eine Kiste darunter geflossen, die ich dann nochmal entsorgen musste.
Jetzt muss ich das nicht mehr und ich bin auf Wolke sieben, es ist so schön, es so geil zu sagen so, oh Spinattopf, den wasche ich ab, aber kein Problem. Und ich muss mir keine Sorgen machen, dass es irgendwo ist, ich meine, klar, ein paar Wochen ist wieder verstopft, aber deswegen, wenn deine Erwartungshaltung so niedrig ist, dass selbst ein funktionierender Abfluss dich glücklich macht, ist doch fantastisch. Ich finde wirklich auch, weil, also Menschen sind auch anpassungsfähig, Menschen sind total anpassungsfähig. Eine Situation ist scheisse, im ersten Moment denkt man, oh nein, oh nein, nein, das werde ich nicht überleben, wie kriege ich das hin, wie kann man ohne Abfluss existieren? Ja. Und dann kriegt man es dann doch ganz gut hin. Ich habe nämlich neulich, das fand ich sehr interessant, es war eine Charakterstudie, eine grosse Feier gefeiert. Und. Herzlichen Glückw. Plötzlich, ja, ja, alles zu spät. Schön, dass du geboren bist und alles Gute. Nee, eine Feier. Meine Erwartungen sind unten Feier jetzt. Okay, okay. Und dann habe ich, dann waren sehr viele ... Herzlichen Glückwunsch im Allgemeinen. Leute haben Getränke gekauft, sehr schwierig festzulegen, wie viele Getränke man braucht für diese Anzahl von Leuten. Und plötzlich war es Tonic Water alle
für die Gin Tonics.
Ende der Party für mich.
Also Florentin war da raus gewesen.
Da wäre Florentin spätestens raus gewesen.
Und dann habe ich
ein paar Freunde am Start gehabt, die mir geholfen haben.
Und die wussten, dass ich
wahrscheinlich nervös werde, wenn das Tonic Water
war. Sie konnten es ja ablesen am Gesicht, ganz klar.
Die Lippe gezittert. So stand und dann sind sie nochmal losgegangen, zum Kiosk nebenan und haben Tonic Water nachgekauft. In der Zeit sind alle umgeschwenkt, die ganze Feier. Also es ist mir aufgefallen, Leute, die feiern, oder ich glaube, wahrscheinlich kann man es auch einfach im nüchternen, wie auch immer Zustand, in allen Zuständen festhalten, sind sehr anpassungsfähig. Die Geträn Leute, die feiern oder ich glaube, wahrscheinlich kann man es auch einfach Menschen im nüchternen, wie auch immer Zustand,
in allen Zuständen festhalten,
sind sehr anpassungsfähig. Die Getränke,
die es gibt, die man denen gibt,
sind die meistgehandelsten Getränke
bei denen im Kopf auf der ganzen
Welt. Wenn du eine Paulana
Spezi in den Kühlschrank stellst, ein paar
Leute auf der Party
lieben Paulana Spezi.
Sie können sich nicht erinnern, wie sie jemals was anderes getrunken
haben. Dann ist Tonic Water weg.
Gin Tonic ist
Das war es für heute. Leute auf der Party lieben Paulana Spezi. Sie können sich nicht erinnern, wie sie jemals was anderes getrunken haben. Dann ist Tonic Water weg. Gin Tonic ist als Getränkeliste gestrichen. Und sind super bereit, sind alle auf ein anderes Getränk umzuschneigen. Und da habe ich gesagt, Leute, ihr müsst jetzt nicht losziehen, noch neues Tonic Water kaufen. Leute steigen um. Und das haben sie gemacht. Leute steigen um. Ist super spannend. Leute sind so anpassungsfähig. So. Und wie haben die dann reagiert auf das neue Tonic Water? War das dann eine Enttäuschung? Man kann keine, das habe ich auch gemerkt, man kann keine Getränke einführen neu auf die Feier. Das heißt, wenn es einmal gestrichen ist, dann war plötzlich waren wir Tonic Flaschen da, Leute waren verwirrt. Leute standen so rum und haben geguckt, was ist das? Man müsste eigentlich mal so eine Doku machen mit so einer Werner HerzogStimme über die ganze ... Sie stupsen das so an. Ja, weil es ist ja ein merkwürdiger Moment, weil sie haben sich ja mit dem Verlust schon abgefunden, dass sie wieder in einer Serie eine Figur stirbt, man durchlebt all diese Emotionen und dann kommt die wieder und es ist nie so, dass man sagt, oh geil, aber man kommt nicht damit klar, dass man sich schon von ihr verabschiedet hat und jetzt ist sie wieder da und so ist bei Tonic Water auch. Jetzt ist Tonic Water wieder da. Die Gruppe hat das schon verabschiedet. Dann werden die Fragen auch gestellt. Was ist Tonic Water im Kern eigentlich? Moment mal, was trinken wir hier eigentlich? Leute, Leute, Leute, stopp, stopp, mach die Musik aus, mach die Musik aus, mach die Musik aus, Stefan. Ähm, warum heißt Tonic so ähnlich wie Toxic? Leute? Ähm, Clarice, hier Clarice. Ja? Clarice wieder. Ich kann das Mikrofon einfach nehmen von der Karaokebox. Nimm sie bitte einfach, nimm sie. Okay, hi, hi Stefan. Ich glaube, ich spreche für alle, wenn ich meistens nicht sage. Ist es okay? Ja, okay. Ich glaube, ich spreche für alle, wenn ich sage, ist es okay? Ja, okay. Ich glaube, ich spreche für alle, wenn wir kein Tonic Water mehr brauchen. Tonic reimt sich auf Toxic, das haben wir im Reimkurs gelernt. Alle Storylines kommen hier gerade wieder zusammen. Und wir würden uns einfach freuen, wenn du Tonic Water zusammen mit den Lügendetektoren einfach rausschmeißt. Und wir einfach wieder, keine Weisswein? Ja, Weisswein einfach zum Beispiel. Okay, ja, vielen Dank. Clarice. Danke Clarice, sie spricht für uns alle. Sie spricht für uns alle. Wenn es Clarice nicht gäbe, würde niemand für uns sprechen. Und so spricht sie für uns alle. Außer unsere Taten. Wie würdest du in dem Drehbuch dieses Ja, im Englischen geil, ne? Shrugs shoulders, Shrugs shoulders. Zug mit den Schultern. Die kleinstmögliche Zustimmung. So, ist mir fast egal, aber noch auf der positiven Seite egal. Das ist so, wie wenn die Null, die zählt noch als positive Zahl, aber man könnte auch minus Null sagen, es ist egal, aber es ist trotzdem, man hat sich darauf geeinigt, dass man Null sagt, also es ist technisch gesehen eine positive Zahl, aber eigentlich ist es nur, es ist so ... Es ist Florentin egal, kann man auch einfach schreiben. Oder weniger Action-Text in Drehbüchern, Leute. Ja. Verzichtet mal auf Action-Text. Ja, endlich sag's doch mal jemand. Ich spreche die Dinge aus, die wir alle denken. We see, we see, we see, was sehen wir denn? Ja, beschreibt doch, was wir sehen. Ja, schreibt doch, was da passiert. Ich kann's dir doch vorstellen. We see, we see, we see, immer we see, wir sehen, dass der Vorhang aufgeht.
Ja, der Vorhang geht auf.
Aber stimmt das? Ich habe gehört, dass Oppo, Oppoheimer in der Ich-Perspektive geschrieben wurde.
Also nicht Oppenheimer enters the room, sondern I, Oppenheimer enters the room, I, the brother of death, the bringer of destruction, enters the room calmly. Am becoming the master of the room soon, or so I thought. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Drehbuch nicht gelesen. Ich auch nicht, aber das geht komisch. Es lag aus im Kino, ich habe nicht reingegriffen. Ja, das Libretto liegt aus. Ja, es liegt aus kannst mitlesen, fällst du dann schön mit der Brille und immer mitblättern. Und da gibt es ein schönes Geräusch, als so eine Szene endet und der gesamte Kinosaal blättert gleichzeitig um. Das Drehbuch, das ist wie so ein Wind, was da an Kraft entsteht, die Wind, der von einer Seite des Kinosaals rübergeguckt wird. Weil alle das Drehbuch mitlesen. Das ist ja eben eine schöne Vorstellung, dass man mal zu einem Film, der lange vielleicht schon existiert, wo man das Drehbuch einfach frei erhältlich bekommt, einfach draußen wird es ausgedruckt oder sowas und auf iPads okay, damit der Kinosaal hell erleuchtet ist. Von mir aus. Mein Gott, aber man kann es doch mal drucken. Ist ja, aber es entscheidend. Es ist ja dunkel, ne?
Ah, ja, ja, ja, iPads sind vielleicht dann doch besser. iPads sind vielleicht besser.
Mein Name ist Clarice.
Ich glaube, ich spreche für den ganzen Saal.
Lass uns den Film kurz anhalten, Clarice möchte was sagen.
Nimm dir das Mikro ein.
Oh, danke schön.
Ja, also ich glaube, ich kann hier für alles sprechen, dass wir leider das Drehbuch nicht lesen können, weil es so dunkel ist.
Vielleicht können wir da irgendwas machen mit Lampen oder iPads oder so. An sich finde ich die Idee schon gut. Fucking Clarice einfach. Sie scheint nicht so selbstbewusst, dabei spricht sie immer für alle, öffentlich. Ich weiß nicht, hängt das damit zusammen, dass sie sich einen neuen Buchstaben gekauft hat? Irgendwie seit sie Clarice war, ist sie irgendwie, ich meine Clarice ist so viel selbstbewusster als Clarice. Oh Clarice, ey. Clarice. Fuckin hell, es liebt die, die macht das gut. Ja, es braucht Sprecher. Sie wirkt ein bisschen schüchtern, während sie spricht, das macht gar keinen Sinn. Aber das macht sie sympathischer, finde ich. Ich liebe Clarice. Ich liebe Clarice auch. Ach ja, aber welchen Buchstaben willst du dir aus? Für Tietze? E. Und du wärst dann der Einzige in einer Familie, der Tietze heißt, oder was? Die Tietze sterben eh geradeaus. Oh? Ich bin der letzte Halter des Namens. Was können wir tun? Ich müsste ein Kind zeugen. Ja? Dann hält der Name an. Will ich das, weiß ich noch nicht. Ja. Aber viel Last auf meinen Schultern. Du bist der letzte Tietze. Und jetzt, ach so, das heißt, du hast aber die Möglichkeit, deinen Stamm komplett neu zu definieren. Neuer Name, neues Image. Neues Logo. Neues Logo. Ja, nochmal komplett alles neu, muss ja eingebaut werden in die Font. Das ist dann so ein Pfeil. Aber warst du nicht Samenspender, hast du nicht eh dadurch? Ne, Stammzellenspender. Ach so. Da aber nimmt man leider den Nachnamen nicht. Bei Samenspender auch nicht, streng genommen, aber ich find's gut. Wenn man so, ach du, ein bisschen DNA von mir in sich trägt, finde ich, sollte man auch den Tietze-Appendix hinten dran haben. Ja. Ich war jetzt in der Sneak Preview, das war sehr schön. in Hamburg gibt es ein ganz, ganz tolles Kino, die immer mal wieder, erst mal das ist ein sehr schönes Kino, und die zeigen auch immer wieder alte Filme, zum Beispiel, da kann man coole Marathons machen, jetzt zum Beispiel bei den Herr der Ringe Marathon, finde ich wahrscheinlich spannend, aber jetzt gibt es da auch eine Sneak Preview, und beziehungsweise, gibt es wahrscheinlich schon länger, ich war zum ersten Mal da, und einen ganz scheusslichen Film gesehen.
Aber es ist trotzdem toll.
Du gehst da rein und
du bist mit einem Haufen Leuten, die keine
Erwartungshaltung haben.
Ja. Und es ist völlig
okay. Es ist, wenn
ein schlechter Film läuft. Und es macht ja auch
Spaß, danach über einen schlechten Film zu reden. Absolut.
Und es ist auch toll zu sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Weil du hast keine Erwartungen und man denkt, ach nein, so ein Action-Ding, ach doch, es gibt doch ein bisschen Drama, ach doch, Liebesding, ach doch, Action, oh ja doch, es ist nur Action, okay. Also das entwickelt sich ja so ein bisschen. Ja, und danach muss man dann, kriegt man so einen Chip in die Hand und dann läuft man an so einer Box vorbei, wo so drei Einschublöcher sind, Schlitze, und man kann den gut, ist mir scheißegal und schlecht reinkippen. Wenn alle Chips sind, ist es mir egal drin. Überall ist es anscheinend der Film ist so völlig egal. Aber da würde ich immer denken, da hätte ich Angst. Weil ich erinnere mich immer wieder, ich glaube alle zwei Tage denke ich daran, dass irgendwie, ich glaube es war Star Wars oder Indiana Jones hat irgendein legendärer Film, der so im Testpublikum gezeigt wurde. Du willst nicht das Testpublikum sein. Genau, die wurde im Testpublikum gezeigt und die fanden den alle schlecht. Und jetzt ist es ein legendärer Film geworden, unglaublich erfolgreiches Franchise. Hat man die mal rausgefunden, wer das ist? Hat man die mal zur Rechnung gezogen? Wollen wir einen Podcast machen, wie wir die alle finden und interviewen? Oh ja, finde ich gut. Leben die noch? Die, die in den ersten Star Wars gesehen haben? The biggest mistake in history. Die Leute, die Star Wars als negativ bewertet haben. Wir ziehen sie zu Rechenschaft. Wir ziehen sie einzeln an die Anklagebank. Was mögen die jetzt für Filme? Oder was mögen sie für Filme? Nichts! Das sind die nächsten Robberstar. Das sind die Hinden Gems. Und ich möchte nicht der sein, der jetzt, wenn jetzt irgendwie Casablanca in der Sneak Preview läuft oder so und ich sag, ja, ist ein bisschen öde. Und dann wird der nicht vermarktet und verbreitet und dann bin ich schuld, dass Filmperlenjuwelen nachliegen. Ja, oder das Gegenteil. Du willst auch nicht den schlecht bewerten und dann ist es ein Mega-Hit. Ja, genau. Du willst aber auch nicht einen Film gut bewerten, der danach nicht untergeht. Das ist mir zu viel Druck. Vor allem, ich finde, man kann ihnen nie nach dem Film sagen, ob es ein guter Film ist. Ich hasse das immer. Ich auch. Nach dem Film. Wie fandest du es so, der Film muss wirken, das ist wie so ein Teebeutel, der muss so zwei, drei Tage... Es gibt Filme, bei denen du sehr schnell weißt, die sind einfach scheiße. So, und so ein Film war das, und dann gehe ich da raus, Kumpel und ich waren uns auch einig, die machen dann
dieses Chip in nicht so gut, hat uns nicht gefallen und hinter uns waren Pärchen, so ein süsses Pärchen, so ganz, auch noch nicht so alt, die waren so verliebt und dann waren die so, ach, also uns hat der gut gefallen und machen den Chip in gut und das tat mir so leid, weil es hat die so, es war so plötzlich Druck auf weil wir so und dann so ein Böse ja wie so die zwei ja so grosse Fratzen bezeichnet Town Villains die dann so kommen wir gehen weiter, wir gehen zum Drive-in ja genau auf so Mopeds auch auf so einem schwarzen Badmobil durch die Nacht fahren. So wie so zwei Bösewichtbrüder. Und machen das dann in, ich mochte den Film nicht. Und hinter uns waren dann offensichtlich die Protagonistenhelden, die sich dann nicht getraut haben. In deren Filmen wir nur mitspielen. Also, wir fanden es gut. Ich dachte jetzt schon, das ist ein Pärchen, die haben zwei Chips und dann haben sie unterschiedliche Meinungen, aber wollen das beim ersten Date noch nicht so richtig.
Wie fandest du's denn? Ja, weißt du nicht, wie fandest du's denn? Ja, so und dann irgendwie beide unterschiedlich sofort Ende.
Ende.
Was, du fandest den gut? Es ist gefährlich, so was als erstes Date zu gehen.
Ich hab's gewusst, als du die ganze Zeit gehustet hast. Schau, das war mich schon auch so aufgeregt.
Ja, wenn ich Dinge nicht mag, dann huste ich immer.
Kann so schlecht liegen.
Sehr durchdringbar.
Ja, aber es tat mir dann auch leid. Und dann dachte ich mir, will man überhaupt diese Bewertung abgeben?
Aber auf der anderen Seite, du bist auch, es war keine Marktforschung, es war eine Sneak Preview, ich weiß gar nicht, was die bringt.
Ja genau, was ist das für eine Bewertung?
Spaß.
Am Ende entscheidet die Website, die Website zeigt die Ergebnisse. So ist der Film, The Website, wird es jetzt umgesetzt? Nein, die Website des Kinos zeigt die Ergebnisse der Wahl, wir haben nachgeschaut, 30, 30, 30. Wo sind die letzten zehn? Wo sind, da fehlt doch was. Wer hat seinen Chip nicht abgegeben? Moment. Moment, da laufen noch Leute mit dem Chip rum, die bei der nächsten Sneak Preview zwei Chips in Fundig Gut, die wahrscheinlich selber, wahrscheinlich ist Nolan dabei. Moment. Moment mal, aber angenommen Nolan ist jetzt in dem Kino und sagt, hey, jeder vorne, hey, ja, ich gehe, ich bin Christopher, ey, pass mal auf, bevor, sie redet die ganze Zeit, au, ich werde mein Chip, aua, ich werde mein Chip, ich werde mein Chip nicht abgeben, Jungs, hey, ich werde mein Chip nicht abgeben, nächste Woche kommt mein kommt mein neuer Film Röntgen. Nächste Woche kommt Röntgen. Habt ihr Bock auf Röntgen? Ja, klar, Mann. Hey, dann gebt eure Chips nicht ab und schmeißt die lieber nächste Woche rein, dann ist ein guter Film bei Röntgen, okay? Der Empfinder der Röntgenstrahlen, okay? Krass, wo wären wir ohne ihn? Ja, wahrscheinlich hätte andere Röntgenstrahlen erfunden. Ja, das ist ja Quatsch, wie die Nazis.
Hat er auch gegen die Nazis... Nee. Deutscher, Wilhelm Röntgen. Ja, aber der war später, glaube ich. Später? Oder? Die Nazis, im Krieg wurde nicht geröntgt. Geröntgt. Geröntgt. Pssst. Im Krieg wurde nicht geröntgt. Es wurde nicht geröntgt. Das ist dein zweites Tattoo. Im Krieg wurde nicht geröntgt. Geröntgt. Ich liebe dieses Werk. Also es ist wirklich so, willkommen in Deutschland. Ich röntg, du röntgst, er, sie, es, röntgt, wir röntgt. Aber da bin ich dankbar zu erkennen, Sprache ist nicht gleich Namen. Und das ist, sagt das ganz deutlich. Stefan, wie viele Tattoos willst du noch haben? Du hast so einen kleinen Körper. Ich meine, du hast einen grossen Körper, du bist gross. Aber wenn du die immer so gross schreibst. Schreib die riesig auf. Name, ungleich Wort. Name sind keine Wörter. Und das merkt man beim Röntgt sehr gut. Er sie es Röntgt. Ich glaube, das wäre so mein Problem, wenn ich irgendwie so Fussarzt wäre oder Arzt, dann immer so morgens. Fussarzt oder Arzt? Eins und beiden. Was willst du denn eines Tages werden? Ich habe mich noch nicht entschieden. Entweder Fussarzt oder Arzt. Okay, also du kannst dich auch durch mehr Sachen entscheiden. Ich bin so unentschlossen manchmal. Ehrlich gesagt? Ach, ich weiß nicht wohin, ich weiß nur nicht, in welche Richtung ich lerne. Doch, wenn du Fussarzt oder Arzt werden willst, bist du sehr entschlossen. Eins von beiden wird's, aber was? Aber du kannst dir auch andere Sachen offen lassen, wie Zahnarzt oder Augenarzt oder so. Fussarzt oder Arzt? Wie meinst du denn Arzt? Also Allgemeinmedizin? Allgemeinarzt, ja, für alles oder nur für Fuss, weiß ich nicht. Und in der Praxis und so, oh Gott, bitte nicht, sagst du es richtig, heute sagst du es richtig, heute sagst du es richtig. Ja, mit ihrem Fuss, das sieht nicht gut aus, da würde ich jetzt auf jeden Fall empfehlen, dass wir dem mal röntgen sind. Bitte, was soll man machen? Ich würde gerne einmal die Gelegenheit nutzen, wenn sie jetzt schon hier sind, den einmal zu röntgen nennen. Zu röntgen. Röntgen. Und deswegen hat man sich entschieden, alle sprechen es falsch aus, röntgen. Ich glaube, ich habe mir wieder ein C gebrochen tatsächlich. Ich könnte kurz vor so einer röntgen Situation stehen, weil wir alle erinnern uns natürlich an die 60 Folgen, in denen wir über nichts anderes gesprochen haben, dass ich mein Zeh gebrochen habe. Mein rechter kleiner Zeh ist tot, stand ab im 90-Grad-Winkel vom Fuss offensichtlich gebrochen. Ich gehe natürlich direkt in die Recherche, versuche natürlich erstmal das Problem mit Wissen zu lösen, eher als mit Handlung, erstmal zu versuchen, muss ich überhaupt handeln?
Wissen löst. Wissen löst. Auf meiner
Lieblingswebsite, muss ich handeln?
Punkt, Fragezeichen,
wo erstmal geklagt wird, muss ich überhaupt
was machen? Nicht zu wechseln mit Handelsblatt,
anderes Medium.
Bei Handelsblatt sagt immer ja, Handeln.
Handel, Handel, Handel, sonst würden die sich ja
selber den Ast wegschneiden. Klar, wer macht
sowas? Und dann dachte ich, muss man den
gebrochenen C behandeln und so, und der stand halt
Vielen Dank. Bei Handelsplatz sagt immer ja, Handel, Handel, Handel, sonst würden sie sich ja selber den Ast wegschneiden. Klar, wer macht sowas? Und da dachte ich, muss man den gebrochenen Zeh behandeln und so und der stand halt wirklich ab, also keine Chance. Gut, dass du es vorher überlegst. In der Recherche habe ich aber auch erfahren, dass es nicht ungewöhnlich ist, dass sich Menschen im Laufe ihres Lebens mehrmals sogar vielleicht Zehen brächten. Genau, man isst sieben Spinnen und bricht sich im Schnitt sieben Zehen, beides ungemerkt. Genau, man bricht auch sieben Zehen von anderen Leuten. Man bricht auch Spinnen sehr viele Zehen. Spinnenzehen, ja genau. Und deswegen habe ich mir das einfach abgespeichert und jetzt war ich im Urlaub und ich hatte einen stechenden Schmerz im Fuss und dachte, tut weh beim Laufen und so. Der gleiche Zeh? Nein, diesmal linker Fuss. Auch kleiner Zeh oder Ringzeh? Das ist das Ding. Unklar. Es strahlt. Es strahlt, es wandert, der Schmerz ist nicht ganz. Das ist das Ding. Der sitzt nicht fest. Der ist manchmal hier, manchmal da. Der bewegt sich, der ist mobil, der Schmerz, und deswegen dachte ich mir, naja, wenn der irgendwie so weiter oben, also so, ne, Fuss, man denkt ja immer, Zehen sind nur diese Fleischknöppel vorne, aber eigentlich ist der Zeh ja ganz lang, ganz in den Fuss rein, aber die hängen ja alle zusammen, also der Fuss ist ja, als wären so die beiden untersten Glieder der Hände einfach zusammengewachsen und nur die obersten gucken raus, aber die anderen sind ja noch ja noch da. Die sitzen im selben Boot, aber die sind unterschiedliche Zehen. Findest du Füsse geil? Findest du Füsse so richtig geil? Ich hab's noch nie verstanden, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass eine Faszination da irgendwann entsteht, aber irgendwie noch nicht so geil. Ich versteh's ein bisschen, ich versteh's so. Also ich meine, es kann schon ein schönes Körperteil sein, auf jeden Fall, aber die Erotik erschließt sich mir noch nicht hundertprozentig. Ich finde es lustig ein bisschen, wenn man es vergleicht, weil es ist dann lustig, wenn man sich anguckt, dass Affen ja Hände als Füsse haben. Genau. Die haben unten auch zwei Händchen. Die können Doppel-Jazz-Hands machen. Die können alleine applaudieren wie eine ganze Gruppe. Und zu wissen, dass wir daher irgendwo aus der Richtung kommen, mit Händchen, Jazz-Hand-Händchen als Füsschen, finde ich, sehen unsere Füsse lustig aus. Das stimmt, ja. Platz, als hätte jemand Hände falsch gemalt. Als wären die so aus Lehm so runtergefallen. Als hätte man so eine Kinderzeichnung real umgesetzt. Genau. Und da finde ich sie lustigig. Und dann diesen Fussfetisch kann ich, das ist so ein Fetisch, den kann ich so ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Es ist so geringfügig ausgeprägt. Macht doch immer eure Tests. Es gibt so eine Fetisch-Website, da kann man herausfinden, worauf man steht. Was ich eine alberne Idee finde, das weiß man ja schon. Naja, manche muss man schon in die richtige Richtung gedrängt werden, zum Beispiel, ich merke das immer wieder bei Algorithmen, so TikTok oder Instagram, dass der schon checkt, dass ich was mag, was ich gar nicht so formuliere, so. Und plötzlich schaue ich Tischtennis-Videos an und hätte das jetzt gar nicht aufgezählt als Hobby. Aber der denkt, oh, bin ich dabei. Gut, du musst Dingen ausgesetzt werden, um zu wissen, was du magst. Okay, gut, aber die Webseite macht das, der listet ja Dinge auch. Ach so, ich dachte, die zeigt dir ein Porno zu jedem Fetisch der Welt. Und misst deine Gehirnströme. Und guckt dann, was genau passiert. Wow, fetisch.com ist die most advanced Website im Internet. Ja, du musst es ja mal angesehen haben oder probiert haben. Ja, okay, das verstehe ich. Das verstehe ich, aber das ist es leider nicht. Das finde ich auch cool. Bei mir ist TikTok inzwischen nur noch Family Guy. Es ist einfach Family Guy. Das ist so lustig. Ja klar mag ich Family Guy. Also vielen Dank Algorithmus. Ich will es nicht immer gucken. Vielen Dank Algorithmus, dass du mir das mal gezeigt hast, mir einen lustigen Clip zeigst. Natürlich gucke ich mir den bis zum Ende an. Natürlich gucke ich mir bis zum Ende an, wie Stewie weinend Hamilton singt. Ja, es ist ein Lacher. Wo ist die Frage? Natürlich, natürlich, natürlich. Aber ich will nicht danach, danach der nächste, literally der nächste TikTok-Kram soll nicht wieder Family Guy sein. Ja, aber denk doch mal, wie mir das bei TikTok abläuft. Es einfach, Chef, wir haben ihm alles Mögliche gegeben, wir haben ihm Pickelausdrück-Videos, wir haben ihm Fuss-Videos gegeben, er reagiert nur auf Family Guy, Family Guy, Family Guy, den ganzen Tag, alles andere, wir haben Kochrezepte gegeben, tanzende Kinder, alles was er reagiert ist Family Guy. Was sollen wir machen, wir haben nur noch 16.000 Clips. Heissen wir TikTok oder heissen wir verdammt nochmal Family Guy TV? Nein. Nein, wir heissen TikTok. Wir heissen TikTok und das steht für hin und her, die Zeit vergeht … Technischer Intelligenzkonzern theoretisch ohne … Kern. Kern. Ach, ich dachte immer, das ist die Uhr, die läuft, dass man bald stirbt und einfach seine Zeit verschwindet. Nein, nein, es ist ein Familienunternehmen. Sind Sie Herr Tog? Ich bin Herr Tog. Was ist mit Herrn Tick passiert? Ich kann nicht drüber reden, die Frage darfst du mir nie wieder stellen. Okay, tut mir leid, Tog. Es war ein Bootsunfall. Es war ein Bootsunfall. Ein Geburtsabst, ein Bootsunfall. Es war ein Bootsunfall. Es war ein Bootsunfall. Warum ich dieselbe Unfall so betone, das sei jetzt mal dahingestellt. Okay, war er in einem anderen Boot und sie in dem einen oder war es einfach dann sie beide im selben Boot?
Aber das ist, wie man sich sofort entlarven kann, wenn man nicht sagt Bootsunfall, sondern es war ein Bootsunfall.
Ja, Auto-Unfall.
Okay, aber deswegen, du hast kein gutes Poker-Face und man merkt es direkt, man merkt es dir direkt an, du kannst es nicht verstecken.
Wie ist er gestorben bei einem Autounfall?
Warum sollte man das so betonen?
Einfach Stille.
Ja, okay.
Können wir den Lügengetektor doch noch machen?
Nein, den kannst du weg. Wir wollen den gar nicht.
Herbert, pack den wieder ein. Brauchst du nicht auspacken.
Roll die Kabel wieder.
Soll wir ihn schon hochtragen aus dem Keller.
Ja komm, dann machen wir ihn. Ach, sei nicht immer so angepisst.
Fucking Herbert, ey. Was ist das für ein Gericht? Verdammt nochmal. So ein Hochroll. aus dem Keller. Ja komm, dann machen wir ihn. Ach, sei nicht immer so angepisst, fucking Herbert. Was ist das für ein Gericht, verdammt nochmal, ist alles so leger.
So ein Hochrein, so ein Kulier ist ja, Lügen. Die drei mal hochgeschneppt!
Mit so einem Erdinger Weissbischert anstelle ich mir den.
Ja, ich habe mich jetzt auch ein bisschen mit mittelalterlicher Gesundheit beschäftigt. Also ich bin so ein bisschen abgedriftet über diese Zehnnummer, weil dann war es so, ja, was macht man gegen Schmerz und so und was soll man machen, soll ich zum Arzt und dann war ich relativ schnell, weil ich, klick dann nicht so auf die seriösen Links, sondern eher auf die Quatsch Links und dann war ich relativ schnell bei Adalas und der vier Säftelehre und dann gibt es ja die Idee im Mittelalter, du hast vier Säfte in dir, die in der Harmonie stehen müssen. Ich blute gelbe Galle, schwarze Galle und Schleim und die vier sind in der Balance und wenn es Missbalance gibt, dann bist du krank. Und dann musst du die gewisse richtigen Dinge essen, um wieder reinzukommen. Und das ist einfach kompletter Quatsch, aber es ist eine Idee. Aber man hat sich sehr darauf geeinigt damals. Und dann, wenn du zum Beispiel zu viel Blut hast,
nee, stimmt nicht, dann bist, ich weiss nicht mehr,
irgendwas bist du Choleriker, ich glaube bei Weiss, bei Schleim bist du Choleriker und dann musst du die richtigen Sachen essen, um wieder die anderen Säfte zu kriegen,
weil man merkt, du bist zu wütend, ist Huhn.
Oder meinen Sie Cholera?
Oder ist grüne Sachen.
Nee, nee, nee, Choleriker.
Cholera, ja.
Nein, hat damit nichts zu tun.
Ich meine, wir sind im Mittelalter, wir sind ziemlich dumm, aber wir sind nicht dümmer als ... Wir müssen nicht rindigen, um herauszufinden, ob du Cholera oder Choleriker bist. Aber ich finde, ich liebe diese überholten Konzepte, nach denen Menschen wahrscheinlich Jahrhunderte dann gelebt haben und gesagt haben, da musst du jetzt unbedingt mehr rotes Fleisch essen, du hast zu wenig Blut. Ja, okay. Und dann halt Unmengen rotes Fleisch. Ein einfach noch schlimmer gemacht. Viel schlimmer gemacht.
Aber es war dann im Zweifel was der Teufel.
Aber vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob da moderne Fussärzte oder Ärzte vielleicht sich melden
können, vielleicht ist da so
ganz grob vielleicht was dran, also
so, oder ist es völliger
Nonsens, weil bei vielen Sachen ist
ja so, keine Ahnung, so grob
was dran, ja, dass man irgendwie sagt,
keine Ahnung, Kräutertee bei
irgendwas, das ist vielleicht schon okay
oder nicht so schlimm. Ich glaube, Adela
Vielen Dank. so, keine Ahnung, so grob was dran, ja, dass man irgendwie sagt, keine Ahnung, Kräutertee bei irgendwas, das ist vielleicht schon okay oder nicht so schlimm. Ich glaube, Adalas ist immer schlecht, ich glaube, das ist nie gut. Mehr Blut will man eher. Einfach, du willst eher mehr Blut. Naja, das stimmt aber auch nicht. Von Stefan Tietze willst du die Stammzellenblut haben. Nee, man will mal Anti-Aids-Blut. Du willst das richtige Blut haben. Aber deswegen habe ich jetzt letzten Endes mich dazu entschlossen, nicht zum Arzt zu gehen. Mein Fuss soll weiter vor sich hin vegetieren, weil letzten Endes, du sagst, Füsse sind geil, aber ich sage, Füsse sind mir egal. Ich stelle mir vor, dass da diese wirklich alle schon wie so ein Baum, wo so alle Äste schon mal gebrochen sind, wo die wieder neu zusammengewachsen sind, der mittlere Zeh wächst mit dem Äusseren zusammen. Und das ist alles wirklich so komplett durcheinander. Und die Zehen sind übereinander und die verschlingen so ineinander. Erzähl vom Nagelpilz. Der Nagelpilz frisst sich wirklich durch. Der ist oben drauf und dann juckt so ein Zeh. Und dann kratzt du so diesen ein Zeh. Erzähl von diesen kleinen Sockenfusseln, die in den Fingernageln. Und dann hast du die Sockenfussel, weil die Zehennägel sind viel zu lang. und dann schneidest du die und dann wächst der Zeh. Erzähl von diesen kleinen Sockenfusseln, die in den Fingernageln die Fussnägel drücken. Und dann hast du die Sockenfussel, weil die Zehennägel sind viel zu lang und dann schneidest
du die und dann wächst der Zeh
ein und dann eitert es da schön den
Zeh raus und dann klappt
dieser komplette Zehennagel da einmal
so oben und dann
Hey,
kein King Shaming,
was du brauchst. Eben. was immer dein Boot fliessen lässt, was immer dein Boot zum Fließen bringt. Ich war in Hamilton, im deutschen Hamilton, wir haben Hamilton gesehen. Alexander Hamilton. Alexander Hamilton. Sein Name ist Alexander Hamilton. Ich bin ein Bastard, weise. So, in der Richtung. In Hamburg. In Hamburg gesehen, direkt an der Reperborn kann man sich das angucken. Oh, sicher. Und es hat richtig Spaß gemacht, es hat richtig Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, ein paar Reihen vor mir war Klaus Badelt in der gleichen Aufführung. Aber Moment mal, wir stehen noch in Kontakt mit Klaus Badelt. Wir stehen in Kontakt mit ihm, er steht nicht so sehr in Kontakt mit uns. Wir haben ihn angefragt, ob er nicht Lust hat, das neue Podcast-Ufo Intro zu komponieren, damit dann das Babelsberger Filmorchester das einspielen kann und wir ein neues geiles Intro haben. Das ist die Idee. Schwierig, aber weil er ist der beste Komponist aller Zeiten. Er hat Flutter Karibik komponiert, mein Lieblingssoundtrack, Till This Date. Und ich glaube, er war da. Ich habe ihn aus den Augen verloren. Ich bin sofort, als es erlaubt war, aufzustehen für Standing Ovations, bin ich aufgestanden, um ihn in Augenkontakt zu haben. Dann soll man ja auch quasi, habe ich beim Bootsführerschein gelernt, wenn man etwas nicht verlieren will, jemanden in den Wellen nicht verlieren will, wenn jemand über Bord geht, Mann über Bord, Frau über Bord, muss man drauf zeigen, muss man einen abstellen, der einfach die ganze Zeit drauf zeigt, damit man den nicht verliert im Wasser. Und ich bin aufgestanden und habe seitdem auf Klaus Badel Finger gehabt, um ihn in der Menschenmasse nicht zu verlieren, habe ich verloren. Aber ich bin sofort aufgestanden und habe drauf gezeigt, so als hätte ich ihn als Übeltäter, für was auch immer, für das schlechteste Publikum. Schlechtester Applaus. Ja. Undankbarster Applaus. Habe ich ihm gezeigt, aber er hat aus den Augen verloren, das hätte ich ihn angesprochen da. Wie kannst du jemanden aus den Augen verlieren? Du bist mit Abstand der Grösste im Raum, du hast die besten Chancen, jemanden im Auge zu halten. Ich habe versagt, ich habe versagt. Aber von mir ist auch oben schon die Sicht eingeschränkt. Aber he's a pirate.
He's a fucking pirate.
And up is down and we don't know.
Aber hättest du ihn wirklich angesprochen und gesagt,
Entschuldigung, Herr Badelt, ich habe ihm eine Meile geschrieben.
Aber man sieht ihn ja auch nicht so richtig, man erkennt ihn ja nicht so richtig,
weil er nicht so gesichtsbekannt ist. Ich muss kurz, Klaus Badelt.
Hättet ihr Klaus Badelt erkannt, seid mal ehrlich,
hättet ihr Klaus Badelt in einer Menschenmenge mit Steven Soderberg und Aaron Salkin erkannt? So die Leute, die man vom Namen kennt? Ach so, das ist Klaus Badelt. Aber man muss sagen, die Bilder, die im Internet von ihm existieren, sind auch schon alle ein bisschen älter. Ich weiß nicht, wie er heute aussieht. Aber es ergibt schon Sinn, wie er aussah. Und ich glaube, er war es. Er hat ein Distinktivges Gesicht, kann man so sagen. Man erkennt, glaube ich, Klaus Badel. Aber ein bisschen wie Sting, oder? Deutsches Sting. Klaus Badel, deutsches Sting. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo er wohnt. Ich glaube, er wohnt, es steht auch nirgendwo, man weiss nichts über ihn, man findet auch keine Website, wir können ihn nicht kontaktieren. Wir haben ihm bei Instagram eine fucking Nachricht geschrieben, seitdem werden wir von Klaus Badel geghostet, vielen Dank, Universe. dass das jetzt etwas ist, was passiert. Wir werden von einem coolen Komponisten geghostet. Brauche ich nicht in meinem Leben, diese Side-Note. Diese Staffel ist echt albern bisher. Ich brauche nicht diese Fussnote in meiner Biografie. Und übrigens, in diesem Zeitraum wurde er von Klaus Badel die ganze Zeit geghostet. Brauche ich nicht. Warum ist es ein extra Kapitelmarker in meinem Wikipedia-Teil? Ghosting. Stefan Tietze wird von folgenden Personen geghostet. Ja, brauche ich nicht, okay, gut, mag sein, aber ja. Und da habe ich nicht angesprochen, habe ich nicht gesehen. Aber ich glaube, mir war es auch gefallen, ein anderes Gefallen, Publikum war ekstatisch, es war cool, der Cast war absolut total toll, ungesehen, bestes, ähm, bester deutscher Musicalcast bislang, den ich gesehen habe. Richtig, richtig toll. Aber vielleicht hat er sich ja inspirieren lassen von dem Musical und ist sofort aufgestanden, so, ich habe eine Idee, ich habe eine Idee, ich schreibe das deutsche, Konrad Adenauer, ich schreibe das deutsche Hamilton und er ist sofort weg in sein Badet-Mobil und sofort losgefahren. Die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar. Ja. Die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Sie zu schützen ist das höchste Gut. Aber eigentlich ist, glaube ich, war ja Hamilton eher ein relativ unbekannter, so ein D-List-Politiker. Ich glaube, wir müssten nicht Adenauer so Stresemann oder so, jemand, der so ein paar Stufen unter... Einer der Gründerväter, den man nicht so auf dem Zettel hat. Ich dachte, man hätte Hamilton die am Zettel. Er ist literally auf dem Zettel. Er ist die Zehn-Dollar-Note.
Ja gut, aber wie viele Noten haben die denn, die Amis? Die Amerikaner.
Eins, fünf, sechs, zehn.
Aber bei Scheinen ist es doch so, je höher es ist, desto unbedeutender bist du.
Oh, weiß ich nicht.
Bei Lincoln ist er auf fünf Cent, glaube ich.
Was sind die einen Dollar-Note?
Washington ist hundert, ne? Aber Übersetzung ist natürlich wahnsinnig schwierig. Oh ja. Aber fand ich völlig okay. Es gab so ein paar Momente, wo ich gestolpert bin, aber insgesamt hätte ich am Ende meinen Chip in den Hut geworfen. Ja, wirklich? In den Hut? Und es wird natürlich abgesetzt. Natürlich wird es jetzt abgesetzt. Nach nur einem Jahr wird es nicht mehr aufgeführt, weil natürlich gehen dann die Deutschen nicht in fucking Hamilton, sondern weiterhin wollen sie Frozen und König der Löwen und noch mal Starlight Express, mehr Starlight Express. Können wir in jeder Stadt einen Starlight Express, können wir in jeder Stadt neben dem Bahnhof ein eigenes Starlight Express Gebäude haben? Gehst du gerade richtig hart mit der deutschen Musical-Szene ins Gericht? Habe ich das gerade richtig gemerkt? Wenn das so rüberkam, möchte ich es ein bisschen relativieren und ein bisschen weniger hart. Nee, geh ruhig rein. Ich finde es schade, dass dann sowas wird dann nicht weitergeführt. Das ist super cool. War super cool. Gute Übersetzung. Also ich finde, ich hätte es nicht besser gekonnt. Aber das ist ja ... Why did I even bring my thunder? Ich glaube, es gäbe dann so ein paar Sätze, auf die ich genau achten würde. Ja, ja. Wo ich dann nochmal gucken würde. Ja, und manchmal sind die auch dann schwierig. Ja, ich glaube gerade, Hip-Hop ist extrem undankbar, weil das ja auch so ein bisschen so diesen Slang oder dann so ein bisschen Ad-Libs mässig, was glaube ich ganz schlecht funktioniert, wenn man es übersetzt, aber ich meine, man muss es und das kann man auch machen. Was geschah, in diesem Zimmer, in diesem Zimmer, das war gut, fand ich eine gute Übersetzung. Da hat ein Kumpel von mir gesagt, er kannte irgendwen aus dem Cast und die haben angefangen mit hinter diesen Türen, hinter diesen Türen und das haben sie jetzt mit in diesem Zimmer. Das ist ja spannend, dass die Übersetzung während den Proben erst noch entsteht und dann sagt Leute, das machen wir nochmal komplett anders. Das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nicht. Ja, super interessant. Deutsch hat eine ganz andere Sprache als Englisch und ja, ich fand's im Kern gut, vor allem aber hat mir natürlich Inszenierung obviously gefallen, kennen wir ja schon, war aber ganz toll und der Cast war ganz, ganz, ganz brillant. Also schaut es euch an und steckt denen euer Geld in die Rache. In den Rachen, zahlt mehr, zahlt mehr. Geht da hin, weil das ist doch, läuft nicht mehr so lange und ist cool, unterstützenswert. Ja, ich meine, wir sind, glaube ich, so ein bisschen durch die Succession-Phase durch. Mein Wunsch, unendlich reich zu sein, schwindet auch. Aber ich glaube, du musst ja gar nicht unbedingt reich sein, du musst dich nur reich fühlen. So, und deswegen, was ich jetzt... Deswegen ja patreon.com slash das Podcast. Das Podcast-Uvo. Aber du musst dich ja einfach nur reich fühlen und ich glaube, das kannst du auch ganz gut. Zum Beispiel, wenn du einfach immer, wenn du was bestellst, sagst du dazu, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Du sagst einfach, ich hätte gern zwei Kugelnstrattze Teller in der Waffel, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Ja, okay. Also wie teuer kann es sein? Der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Es klingt so, als wären sie sehr reich, genau. Nee, finde ich nicht. Aber meiner Erfahrung nach zahlt man tatsächlich nie wirklich mehr. Wenn du einfach sagst, ja, ich hätte gern Big Mac Menü mit Pommes zu mitnehmen, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Du zahlst es am Ende nicht mehr, aber die Leute denken, wow, der hat richtig Geld. Ja, wenn du sagst, er hätte gern Er ist in einem fucking McDonalds. Er hätte gern zwei Tickets für Oppenheimer und eine kleine Pommes. Der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Ich find's auch übergriffig. Wer ist Pommes im Kino? Popcorn perfekt. Auch nicht so übergriffig im Geruch. Popcorn wäre auch zu hart. Nee, find ich gut. Einfach sagen, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Ich hatte jetzt ein paar Situationen, wo ich ein Budget festlegen musste. Oh, okay. Für wen? Kann ich nicht sagen. Und da ist meine ... Ich manage ein Eishockey-Team und ich musste das Budget für die Trikots festlegen, aber ich kann nicht drüber sprechen, welches Tier genau mein Team trägt. Und dann musste ich ein Budget festlegen und da ist meine Erfahrung, der Preis spielt sehr wohl eine Rolle, denn wenn man jemandem sagt, ich hätte gerne das und das, es darf bis so und so viel kosten, es wird immer der Preis. Es wird exakt so viel kosten. Es wird immer der obere Preis. Es wird nie drunter. Ja, also wir können das gerne so machen, es soll maximal kosten, maximal ein Tausend. Aber dann kannst du auch sagen, ja, bestellen Sie bitte Team-Trikots für maximal tausend Euro, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Also es ist auch zweitausend. Nein, bis tausend Euro, der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Sie sagen nichts wie einen Preis. Ja, aber der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Aber dann sagen sie keinen Preis. Bis 1000 Euro. Man spielt ja doch ein bisschen eine Rolle. Keine Rolle. Kleine Rolle. Keine Rolle. Mini Rolle. Vielleicht kleine Rolle. Nebenrolle. Wenig Rolle. Okay. 1000 Euro. Alles klar. Aber es klingt gut. Es klingt gut, dass du so sagst, ich kann es mir leisten, ich kann es mir leisten.
Ja, mein Tipp dazu, wenn ihr noch richtig, richtig reich rüberkommen wollt, geht nicht in McDonalds und sagt, spielt keine Rolle.
Geht so schön zu Warpiano und sagt, müssen wir es nicht in drei Gang Menü, Geld spielt keine Rolle.
Können Sie mir bitte vielleicht den Parmesan bringen? Preis spielt keine Rolle.
Das ist ja eh umsonst.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
So komm, so bist du dann, So wirkst du plötzlich reich. Weniger von diesem Rumge. Stören Sie mich nicht mit Ihren Details und Preisen. Das spielt keine Rolle. Ich habe ja, Josephine, ich habe ja seit drei Jahren keine Zahl mehr gesehen. Mir sind Preise egal. Ich habe keine Zahl. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie eine 3 aussieht, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Wenn Sie mich jetzt hier direkt auffordern würden, eine 3 zu schreiben, ich könnte es nicht, ich habe leider keine Zahlen mehr gesehen, so lange bin ich schon reich. Weil sie nie, fahren sie nie im Zug oder fliegen sie nie? Nein, ne, ich mein, Chauffeur macht das, ich sag, ah, nach Oslo und dann macht der das und dann, ah, uh, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep und Zahlen und welches, welches Flugzeug und so, das machen die.
Okay, alles klar.
Wer reich ist, hat keinen Kontakt mehr zu Zahlen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Mathematik. Am Anfang, die kleinen Kinder rechnen mit Zahlen, aber irgendwann trennt sich die Spreu vom Weizen und die Erwachsenen rechnen nur noch mit Buchstaben. Man kann übrigens supergeil Leute überführen, dadurch, dass sie reich sind, wenn man fragt, was kostet gerade Milch? Ah ja. Oder was kostet gerade ein Ei? Aber ich habe gehört, dass ... Was kostet gerade Mehl? Das ist so ein Klassiker... Was kostet gerade 20 Gramm Zucker? Ich weiß nicht, welches Rezept ich gerade... Was kostet ein Pfannkuchen? Machen wir es kurz. Machen wir es so. Ich glaube, das ist so eine klassische Frage für Sommerinterview, wo die Politiker dann mal so ein bisschen im legeren Rahmen interviewt werden. Und ich habe auch mal gehört, dass manche Politiker vor diesen Interviews extra nochmal Preise recherchierenieren, extra noch mal so Karteikarten, Tetra Pak Milch 90 Cent, eine Möhre 12 Cent, Snickers 89 Cent und das dann alles drauf haben, damit sie dann, was auch verräterisch ist, wenn der Politiker es zu genau weiß, etwas so, was kostet 1,29 Euro bei Norma, 1,26 Euro bei Edeka und 1,24 Euro bei Edeka. Was kostet eine Packung Fred Ferkel? 1,19 Euro. Oh, das ist exakt richtig, Herr Scholz. Ja, das geht auch nicht. Man muss dann so ungefähr 1,23 Euro. Ungefähr so was, weiß ich gar nicht. Mich interessiert stimmen Florentins Preise, die er gerade gesagt hat in diesem Bit, die nichts mit der Realität zu tun haben. Aber du weißt ja, für mich der Preis spielt keine Rolle. Nice. Wenn auch für euch der Preis keine Rolle spielt, dann eine schöne Woche. Für alle anderen, beisst euch da durch. Weiss euch durch den harten Winter. seht diese Woche an wie so ein dickes Karamell-Toffee, wo ihr einfach euch durchbeissen müsst. Okay, nice, durchbeissen als Euphemismus. Einfach durch damit, einfach schön rein, so ein richtig dicker Brockenkaramell, so eine Karamellschicht. Dann ihr. Cool, ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche, macht's gut.
Vielen Dank nochmal an Michel für das fantastische Intro und ansonsten freuen wir uns natürlich auch auf nächste Woche, wenn ihr wieder mit dabei seid vielleicht, wenn es wieder heißt Stefan. Wir heben ab zum das Podcast-Uvo-Podcast-Podcast-Projekt. Heben ab, macht's gut, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal. Es ist eine Wesperer-Produktion. It's a West Bird production.